موجود سخريه تجتاح العراق بعد تسريب قرار
منع تسريب الخطابات الرسميه ومحاوله
لتفسير ما يجري في عالم التقنيه تسريح
بعشرات بالالاف رغم ان الوظائف هي الاكثر
طلبا وترامب يقاضي صحفي ودار نشر بتهمه
سوء استخدام صوته ويطالب بالتعويض 50
مليون اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في العراق
اصدرت خطاب رسمي تحديدا من مكتب رئيسها
محمد شيء السوداني
مؤسسات الدوله
الموظفين المسؤولين عن تسريب الوفاء
الرسميه ومحاسبه كل شخص يتغاضى عن
المخالفات وما يطبك العقوبات بحقها لكن
الشيء الكوميدي اللي صار حقيقه انه خطاب
منع تسريب الوثائق الرسميه هو نفسه هذا
يتسرب وعليه واتساب وفيسبوك وتويتر
العراقين جالسين بتداوي له صور للخطاب
بنصفه وترويجته والتوقيع اللي عليه كمان
وطبعا ما يحتاج يقول لكم انه الموضوع تحول
لكم ماده اساسيه ليه سخريه العراقين على
المنصات
من العام الماضي والحنا متابعين معاكم
اخبار العقالات اللي بتعلنها شركات
التكنولوجيا بحق موظف فيها احداث اليوم
شركه التكنولوجيا في باللي دخلت على خط
تصريح الموظفين واعانه راح تسرح 7% او
2000 موظف يعني فيها وفي ايميل حتى الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه بي باللوم على البيئه
الاقتصاديه الصعبه والخوف من الركود
الاقتصادي اللي بيشهدوا العالم وكمان حاله
عدم اليقين حول الوضع العام وانخفاض اسهم
الشركه اكثر من 50 في المئه العام الماضي
الاعلان هذا من شركه تكنولوجيا عن تسريحه
الموظفين والاول فمن قبل الاعلى نتعد
الشركات عن تسريح الالاف من الموظفين
واللي منها حتى تويتر اللي سرحت 50% من
الموظفيها من بعد ما استلم ال ماسك الشركه
وتلقى 7500 موظفه رسائل بريد الكتروني
بالتخلي عن خدماتهم واما شركه كانت اعلنت
كمان عن تسريح 11,000 موظف واللي بتعت اول
عمليه تسريح رئيسيه وكبيره في الشركه ومن
بعدها اعلن شركه مايكروسوفت عن الاستغناء
عن 10,000 موظف بسبب تراجع مبيعاتها جوجل
فكمان اعلنت عن تسريح 12000 موظف من
موظفيها كمان بسبب التخوف من الركود
الاقتصادي وحتى امازون اعلنتن بالخطط او
بتخطط التسريح 18000 موظف بسبب انتهاء
ازمه كورونا وانخفاض المبيعات اون لاين
يعني ازمه كبرى وعامه في كل القطاع الاف
المسرحين وكل وسائل الاعلام بس شغاله
دراسه والتحليل ومحاوله فهم ايش اللي جالس
بيصير في عالم شركات التقنيه لكن حقيقه
يعني في ظل كل هذا التسريح في شيء لافتته
غريب في نفس الوقت واللي هو انه قوائم
وظائف العام وظائف المستقبل كلها جلسه
مليانه بوظائف
تحديد حصول مطور البرمجيات على المركز
الاول في قائمه افضل الوظائف لعام 20 23
يو اس نيوز ان وظائف محلل الامن معلومات
مدير اي تي مطور بكل كمان من افضل الوظائف
السنه بحسب القائمه هذا غير الكثير من
القوائم الاخرى اللي مليانه ايضا بوظائف
تكنولوجيا فكيف يعني هذه هي وظائف السنه
والمستقبل والمجالات اللي بنشجع الناس
انهم يدرسوها وكل هذه الشركات جلسه بتسرح
موظف فيها يعني كيف نقدر نفسر هذا الموضوع
وهذه الفجر
معنا عبد العزيز طوال السنوات الماضيه
فعليا كان هذا اللي بينقال انه لازم تدرسه
لازم ادخال البرمجه في المدارس كل هذا
الكلام لانه هو هذا المستقبل الان نحن
شايفين قطاع اللي هو بيعتبر قطاع المستقبل
بيستغنى عن موظفينه كيف نقدر نفهم هذا
الشيء
طبعا اختي ساره فعلا الموضوع جدا هامم
والتسريح اللي حصل الماضي لا يعني انه
هناك نهايه عقبه تقنيه المعلومات او تطور
التقني اا ال- ال- هي فقط مرحله تمر بها
اغلب الصناعات على مستوى العالم والتقنيه
في النهائي ليست في معزل عن بقيه ال- ال-
المجالات التسريحات الماضيه يعني همم لها
اسباب كثيره ليست فقط الناحيه الاقتصاديه
وان كان في مؤثر رئيسي لكن هناك نواحي
اخرى على سبيل المثال تطور السوق وتغير
التقنيات الموجوده في جعلت فعلا مثل هذه
الشركات انها تبدا تتوجه الى يعني تقنيات
مجالات اخرى كذلك من الاسباب المهمه وهي
التنافس الكبير في ما بين هذه الشركات
اللي خلق همم تقنيات همم جديد اما جعل بعض
الشركات تتخلى عن تقنيه قديمه يعني في نفس
الحال اكيد بتتخلى عن الموظفين الذين
يقومون عن يقومون على تشغيل المثل هذه
التقنيات اليوم همم يعني همم لا تزال في
قائمه ابرز المجالات التقنيه في ابرز
المجارات الوظيفيه المطلوبه على مستوى
العالم ليس فقط في مجال مثلا البرمجيات
والمجالات التقنيات التي نعيشها لا ايضا
اي في في مجال التقنيات الناشئه لانه
تقنيات المتطوره على سبيل الذكاء
الاصطناعي او صدق مثال تعلم الاله على
سبيل المثال الواقع الافتراضي والواقع
المعذب فلذلك الان بدانا في السوق الجديد
بدانا في الثوره الصناعيه ليست فقط الرابع
انما الخامسه بدانا في همم ايجاد شركات
جي بي تي 3 ما الذي احدثه من ثوره
الصناعيه كبيره جدا جعلت الشركات التقنيه
مثل جوجل وفيسبوك وغيرهم شركات همم تتنافس
من يعني يمتلك زمامه من الامور في هذه
التقنيه لدينا همم مثلا كمبيوتر
والمنافسه الكبيره جدا ما بين شركه جوجل
واي بي ام غير المشركات دائما
سيكونوميه والتي تعتبر همم ثوره القادمه
في التقنيات همم
التقنيات التي ستقود القادمه لا تزال
الشركات التقنيه تتربى في عرش قائمه من
يتحكم في الصناعه همم على مستوى العالم
قائمه افضل شركه اغنى الشركات التقنيه على
المستوى العالم ثمانيه منها لا تزال شركات
تقنيه طيب هذا اللي بتقول يعني همم يخليني
اقول انه يمكن هذه الشركات طيب وظفت اكثر
من ما كانت تحتاج يعني
في وقت توظيفها تحتاج مثل هذه الطاقات لو
اخذنا على سبيل المثال جوجل ولا فيسبوك
ولا غيره كان يحتاجون حجم كبير جدا من
الطاقات في بعض التقنيات المتخصصه في
الفتره القادمه مع يعني الوضع الاقتصادي
في الفتره الحاليه ومع ايضا تغيير
التقنيات التي تعمل عليها هذه الشركات
جعلت انه الافضل لها ان تستثمر في طاقات
جديده او انها تقلل
عبد العزيز اللي يخوف في هذا الموضوع يعني
الان مثلا نحن يكون موضوع الذكاء الصناعي
فالناس تبتدي مثلا تدخل في مجال دراسه
الذكاء الصناعي بعدها بشويه يطلع شيء ثاني
مثلا ويطيح بالذكاء الصناعي طب يعني يعني
فاهم الدنيا بتتغير والسرعه بتتغير مره
كثيره فايش الواحد يعمل في هذه الحاله
يعني
طبعا التقنيه فعلا متغيره بشكل كبير جدا
والتقنيه يعني كل خمس ست سنوات ياتي جيل
جديد مختلف تماما عن الجيل القديم من
ناحيه من ناحيه تقنيه لذلك لابد فعلا يعني
التقني الموظف الذي يمسك جزء تقني معين
يطور نفسه بشكل دوري اليوم مثلا انا تعلمت
على تقنيه معينه بعد سنتين نزل تحديث
تماما مختلف عن التحديث القديم فاذا لم
اطور من نفسي بطبيعه الحال ساكون متاخر
وبالمناسبه الانتقالات التي حصلت لي عشرات
الالاف من المهندسين التقنيين هذا جيد
وسيد هو طبعا سيء للاشخاص بحداتهم انهم
يجب ان يبحث عن وظائف اخرى ولكن جيد في
الموضوع انه هؤلاء الاشخاص سيبداون في
وظائف تقنيه اخرى ستخلق سوق اخر عشرات
الالاف من المهندسين المتميزين والخبراء
مجالات التقنيه اذا خرجوا من شركه كبيره
سيذهبون لشركات همم صغيره يعني
او ناشئه ومن ثم يخلقون السوق والمنافسه
اخرى قد تقويد في الفتره القادمه المجالات
التقنيه او عفوا ال ال المجادله التقنيه
المختلفه
على هذه المداخله كان معنا عبر سكايب عبد
العزيز الحمادي الخبير التقني شكرا لك عبد
العزيز
[موسيقى]
في جريمه صغيره في المانيا واخبارها ماليه
العالم والسبب انه الجريمه عجيبه وتدافع
بصراحه اعجب يعني طبعا ما في اي مبرر بشكل
خالص
لكن هذه سببها ما يخطر على بال احد اصلا
فخليني احكي لكم القصه مثل ما صارت في
عائله في المانيا من اصول العراقيه بنتهم
طلعت وما رجعت فرح وبلغوا الشرطه وفقدان
بنتها الشرطه اشتغلت تدوير على البنت وفي
الاخير لقيت سيارتها في الغابه وجثه البنت
مرميه على الكرسي الخلفي ونادوا الاهل
اللي تعرفه على البنت وبدات تحقيق في
وفاتها وكيف ماتت خاصه لان البنت كانت
مطعونه 50 طعنه ووشها مشوح الاهل تعرفوا
على بنتهم من لبسها وهيئاتها وسيارتها
والشرطه بدات التحقيق يعني لكن المفاجاه
الصحيح غير كانت لما جاء بعد كم يوم نتيجه
تحليل الدين وطلعت البنت مو بنتهام طيب
مين هذه
بشويه بحث من الشرطه حددوا هويتها وطلعت
فتاه جزائريه وبتشبه بنت العائله العراقيه
بشكل كبير طيب فانا البنت المفقوده هنا
بدات تتكشف تفاصيل الجريمه العجيبه الشرطه
اكتشفت انه البنت اللي وقتها كانت ضايعه
يعني وافتكروها هي الميته اكتشفوا انه هذه
البنت عندها مشاكل وخلافات مع اهلها فقررت
بالتعاون مع احد من اصدقائها من قصبه انها
تعمل فيلم على اهلها وتعمل كانها ماتت
وتهرب هي عاد مع صديقها هذا بس علشان
تقنعهم انها ماتت بتحتاج جثه وهي اصلا
بلوجر فبدات على انستغرام تدور على بنات
شبهها
وتراسلهم وتحاول انه تصاحبهم وترتب لقاءات
معهم وفشلت اكثر من مره لكن اخر مره مع
الفتاه الجزائريه ظبطت معها وهو فقدت
البنت انه تلتقي فيها على اساس الموضوع
اتفاق بخصوص مستحضرات تجميل ولما نلتقوا
فيها قتلوها 50 طعنه في وشها عشان يخدعوا
الشرطه والاهل بالجثه عموما الشرطه لاجت
المجرمين
وقبضت عليهم واللي بان بيواجهوا طبعا
السجن ماذا الحياه اذا تمت ادانتهم
[موسيقى]
الم من جديد الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب راجع للعناوين بقوه خاصه من
وقت الاعلان عن نيته للترشح من جديد لكن
ترامب اليوم في العناوين لاسباب بعيده عن
الانتخابات شويه فالرئيس السابق بيطالب
بتعويض 50 مليون دولار ورفع الدعوه قضائيه
في الموضوع كمان واما خصومه فهم الصحفي
الشهير باب ود ودار النشر
التابعه لشركه الام اللي هي باراما والسبب
هو كتاب صوتي اسمه
بيحتوي على 8 ساعات من مقابلات خام عملها
الصحفي مع ترامب بين عامه 2016
و2020 وبينهم تعليقات صوتيه للصحفي نفسه
حاطينها كمان اعتراض ترامب مفعول الدعوه
بحسب ما قال انه هو ما اعطاهم الاذن
الاستخدام التسجيلات هذه في كتاب صوتي وان
هو سماح فقط انها تتسجل علشان الصحفي يفرغ
منها اللي يحتاجه يعني ويغتصب ويقتبس
تصريحات لترامب يحطها في كتابه اللي بيقول
لي اسمه اريج همم كتبوا هذا الصحفي عن
ترامب طرح كمان في سبتمبر 20 20 ترامب بعد
الدعوه نشر بوست على منصه توت سوشيل وكتب
فيها ان هو راح يواصل مكافحه وسائل
الاعلام الاخبار المزيفه الفاسده والكاذبه
وانه رفع دعوى قضائيه على ود ويرد ودار
النشر اللي تبعته نشرت الكتاب الصوتي
واتهامهم باستخدام صوته بشكل سيء وقال في
الدعوه انهم عملوا كده لانه صوته هو من
اشهر الاصوات في العالم
خصومه المؤلف ودار النشر كمان في بوست
ثاني انه نشرت تسجيلات محاوله لاظهار
بصوره الشرير لكن على العكس هم اللي ظهر
فسادهم وكذبهم واكد انه مستمر في الدفاع
عن الحقيقه والقتال ضد الشر وسيبقى بطل
الحقيقه الرد من دار النشر والصحفي على
الدعوه جاء عامر بيان مشترك قال وفي انه
كل المقابلات مع ترامب كانت اندرتيكر يعني
للنشر وقالوا انه تسجلت بمعلم بعلمه
ترامب وقالوا كمان انه دعوه ترامب ما لها
اساس انه مريضه راح يدافعوا عن انفسهم بكل
قوه وانهم واثقين انه القانون لمصلحتهم من
هيفوز حدا يشوفوا في الفتره الجايه
طيب خليني اقول لكم انه كمان مشاهدينا
النتيجه نحن هنشوفها خاصه من بعد ما كمان
قضى قاضي فدرالي المحكمه الجزئيه
الامريكيه يوم الخميس بعقوبه مليون دولار
على ترامب محامي بسبب قضيه رفضتها المحكمه
وكان رفعها ترامب ضد هيلاري كلينتون و30
قال فيها انهم حاولوا اتلاعب بالانتخابات
الرئاسيه في 2016 لصالحها عن طريق تلطيق
سمعه ترامب وطالبهم بالتوقيت 70 مليون
دولار
[موسيقى]
ليالي مسقط مهرجان انطلق في العاصمه
العمانيه في 19 يناير ومستمر لاربعه
فبراير ومليان فعاليه امس وفي احدى العاب
المهرجان المقامه في مركز عمان للمعارض
والمؤتمرات وقع حادث واتنشر له مقطع مرعب
بصراحه
[موسيقى]
المقطع انتشر والناس بدات الدوله بتسال
ايش صار وكيف ومين الضحايا وعددهم طبعا
مثل العاده الاشاعات كمان بدات وتضاربت
الاخبار والواحد ما اعرف ايش الصح من
الغلط بلديه مسقط فورا في سلسله البيانات
وضحت الموضوع اولا نشرت بيان قالت فيه ان
تاسف للحادث اللي وقع واعلنت لنا بالحق
فيه الاسباب وبتقيم الاضرار وناشده الناس
استقصاء المعلومات من المصادر الرسميه
قالت بلديه مسقط انه الاصابات سته وانه ما
في اي اصابات بليغه لكن رجعت في بيان
الثالث
المستشفى وفي حالتين فقط
حالتهم وتم تحويلهم لاجراء المزيد من
الفحوصات الدفاع المدني العماني هو كمان
اصدر بيان عن التعامل والفرق مع الحادث
وكشف انه الاصابات لسبعه اطفال وسيدنا
نتراوحد بين متوسطه والخفيفه
من اسبوعين تقريبا كنا تناولنا في
برنامجنا قضيه لاعب كره القدم البرازيلي
داني البس اللي اتهم فيها بالاعتداء
الجنسي على فتاه في ملهى ليلي ببرشلونه
واتكلمنا كيف تم القبض عليه مباشره وما
وافق القاضي انه يطلعوا بكفاله وكيف
ناديكم
بعد الاتهامات اللي طالته كيف تطورت
الازمه بسرعه دانيال في السجن والربايات
اللي قالها داخل السجن رواياته يعني تغيرت
عن الحادثه تحديدا هذه خلينا نقول انها
تغيرت اكثر من مره في الاول قال ما كان
وقت الحادثه في المكان بعدها رجع قال انه
او كان مع اصحابه هناك لكن ما يعرف البنت
والعمره شافها بعدين رجع قال انه يعرفها
لكن يومها ما شافها في الاخر اقر انه
شافها وكان في لقاء في الحمام لمده 15
دقيقه وصار بينهم شيء يعني باختصار اعترف
بالقطط والكاميرات لكنه قال انه اللي صار
كان برضا الفتاه اللي بدورها بتاكد انه
هذا الكلام غير صحيح وما كان في شيء
برضاها اليوم في اخبار جديده عن تفاصيل
كفشه كشفها اللاعب المتهم عن الجريمه
وتفاصيلها وهذه التفاصيل يبدا انها حكمت
على زواجه بالنهايه فزوجته اسمها جوانا
سانزو اعاده ازياء من براجواي كانت
البدايه وقفت معه ونشرت اكثر من بوس الدعم
له وقالت لنا مو مصدق انه ممكن يعمل شيء
مثل هذا هذا الموقف منها بعد اعترافات
داني تحول والاخبار اليوم بتاكد انها
تقدمت رسميا بدعوه طلاق ضد زوجها بعد ما
تم تداول الانباء بشكل واسع رجعت وطلعت
كمان في ستوري على حسابه على الانستغرام
وقالت انه اذا في اي قرار بخصوص فهي راح
تعلن عبر حساباتها يعني لا نفت ولا اكدت
الخبر لكن وسائل الاعلام بتاكد موضوع
الطلاق واللي بياكدوا اكثر نظره على
حسابها اللي اختفى منه كل صورهم مع بعض
الا الصور اللي كانت ضمن اعلانات او حملات
دعائيه مشتركه
[موسيقى]
على منصه تيك توك بنشوف محتوى متنوع ويعني
ومشاهد وتحديات عجيبه غريبه بمجرد يعني
ومن بين المحتوى يعني هذا تحديات حتى
خلينا نقول عن تناول كميات كبيره من
الطعام اللي بتتعدى حاجه الشخص واحساسه
بالشبع اللي او الى التخمه يعني يعني
بالعاميه كذا انه بياكلوا بفجع يعني
عارفين واللي بيعملوا هذه التحديات اشخاص
بمفردهم او بيكونوا مثلا
عليها ملايين المتابعين وملايين اللايكات
على تيك توك وفي منهم حتى تركوا اشغالهم
واعمالهم وصار شغلهم بس تحديات الاكل هذه
وبيكتبوا من وراها الملايين
ما ببالغ لما اقول ملايين لانه هاشتاجات
الموضوع عليها مليارات بالمئات مليارات
المشاهدات فيعني مثلا نقدر نلاقي واحد من
الهاشتاقات عليه 115 مليار مشاهده و مثلا
هذه
الهاشتاج هذا المقبق او مقبق للي ما يعرف
ايش معنى هي كلمه كوريه بتجمع كلمتين هم
الاكل والاذاعه ومع بعض صاروا كلمه واحده
بترمز لفيديوهات الناس اللي بتاكل فيها
وهي بتصور فيديوهات وبتتفاعل مع المتابعين
والغريب انه هذول الناس مستعدين يخربوا
صحتهم ويعرضوا حياتهم للخطر باستهلاك
الاكل هذا وكله فضل المشاهدات واللايكات
اللي
يحصلوا عليها ومن وقت انتشر هذا النوع من
المحتوى بشكل كبير وغزل منصه انطلقت
التحذيرات من خطورتها على الصحه وتسببها
بامراض من السمنه للسكري للقلب وغيرها
طبعا من المخاطر الصحيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
صافي
[موسيقى]
سيره المخاطر الصحيه في اشخاص فقدوا
حياتهم بسبب هذا المحتوى والتحديات مثل
نجم تيك توك وفلر اللي بيملك ملايين
المتابعين واللايكات وكان معروف عنه انه
بيعمل تحديات غريبه وعجيبه عن الطعام
وبياكل كميات كبيره ومنها منتهيه الصلاحيه
حتى كمان كجزء من التحديات توفي عن عمر 33
عام بسكته قلبيه ويعتقد انه سبب الوفاء
كان مشاكل صحيه لها علاقه بنمط حياته وكل
الاشياء
ماكدونالدز
[موسيقى]
والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله طبعا في اجمل
ايام الاسبوع الخميس
وحلقه طبعا جديده من تفاعلكم دائما
حلقاتنا متجدده وفيها مواضيع حلوه دائما
تابعونا يعني
مش حلوه تابعونا بالله
[موسيقى]